how much money have you made in total
since joining the academy in deal
selling i think like around 30 30
around 30 to 40 000. in just two months
have you made your money back yet yes
on the
i think first your week hey what's up my
name's samuel leeds i'm about to
introduce you to a very very special
lady from vietnam her name is naomi and
she's recently joined the property
investors academy she's absolutely
smashing it in property here in london
naomi thank you so much for coming to my
house thank you yeah thank you for
inviting me here today yeah it's so
lovely in a viking view yeah thank you
very much so when we met you have you're
an established business business lady
you've got successful businesses in
different different parts of the world
what was it that made you come to the uk
and specifically wanting to do property
like what was it that brought you here
do you know like property you know my my
grandparents my parents do property
before so i know like with property we
already got passive income and we got
capital appreciation
before i only
earn money from different business after
that i put in the property because i
know it's the best thing yes so
i went i watched a lot of youtube about
you and i said like uh insistently i
bought one fan try and ask that asian
cosy max in my company is the max pro so
i said like oh i i watched a lot of
youtube and i found you and i said
you know what specs today i using my
birthday my father said what do you want
to do for my birthday so my brother and
said like i want to go cross court and
meet samuel list yeah and there is a day
i i meet you and today i'm stick with
academy
amazing so you came to the property
investors crash course this was around
it was just about 17 of september you
know the exact date because it's my
birthday so 17th of september so you
came to the property investors crash
course how long have you been living in
the uk
um yeah like living in uk quite long yes
from 2011. okay so yes so i um before
that i lived in singapore right yes but
you're in a rush originally from vietnam
yeah as you know from vietnam and you've
got companies in different countries as
well so you've been a successful
business uh business owner and we we hit
it off straight away because
you you're a business savvy lady you've
got really good energy and um what was
it that made you
come to the uk in the first place was it
to invest in property or did you come
for another reason um actually i study
in my uni in singapore and um i also do
a bit of business in even property and
everything in singapore yeah so um my
husband in uk
yeah he studied um daytime he studied uh
i think that time he studied master in
cambridge university yeah so yeah
because my husband here is like why i
said listen i came here
right okay so he came here for love and
then and then and then when did you
start buying properties in the uk 2018
2018. yes my first hour in 2018. so talk
to me about your first property purchase
actually like um i helping a lot of
people buy the house because i tell a
bit about my background i'm education
consultant
i graduate in msc entrepreneurship in uh
in third university so like
entrepreneurship we helping start the
visit from start to the end yes so um i
also education consultant i helping a
lot of students from overseas like
vietnam thailand hong kong dubai came to
uk to study and helping them like quite
young from six years old until like
study master and psd and go to the
office and cambridge you know
with our asian you got to study top
university is very important with the
parent yes so like i
i got a lot of like um yeah a lot of my
parents and a lot of investors really
want to buy the house and everything so
i said yeah with my husband he like
lecture and like he in academic side he
doesn't want to buy a house even he tell
me like no i said of course i would buy
my first cell with morgan and he told me
like no don't buy the house with more
gas you know like and i said like
so instead of rent we can buy it and we
don't need to pay rent and he said no
and and like you know even my bad
partner yeah my partner visit partner he
told me like okay you need one i bounce
it how first how is 385 000
and he told me like okay uh i like
around 150 000. for more gate they tell
me like okay i got 150 000. you don't
need to get more get
uh pay for it i mean so i don't want to
take more money i get more goods
yeah so i think the mindset everyone
said like they want to prepare all the
full money when they buy it they never
think about and they said you calculate
how much to insure the mortgage even the
cheaper than you pay for the rent but
you know what they're buying a house for
cash in london is very very difficult
and
houses are very expensive and especially
you know most people
you know that might be making 25 30 000
pounds a year to be able to save up to
buy a house is very very hard so talk to
me about the change of mindset you had
then about buying houses for cash and
buying houses with mortgage they don't
like i think like um
after like you know like i
until now i have around 1 000 people buy
the house
1 000 house already until you get home
like uh estate assistant other one i
have ping because i've got
accountability in it my accountant we
got around 500 small business you know
like some new shop a restaurant take
away shop even though like some property
business so you know the way like i know
like about them and they want to buy the
house they need support for me like they
need to find the new you know they want
to find the best house with bmv
20
or even they buy the hardwood location
yeah so like um i helping them to buy
the house so i know how it so actually
way on my experience and i can give them
what is the best price what the bad
location
and what is about you you know okay by
the hour but what is the bad view people
don't know because i go through you know
one or two house oh god we got
experience but with me i helping a lot
of people to buy the house you know
normally in the first house they are not
like you know the first house how they
live but later on in investor now is the
investment they might feel how to invest
and got the passive income you know like
when i came to the class court
and my my chain a lot of a lot of people
even in casco tell me know me why you go
to academy why you go to crash course
and you related everything before even
my with my client and i said no
everything is chained like you know even
with b-r-r-r yeah it's very i love this
chargery and not everyone know about it
yeah yes okay so you so you've been
working you've got many businesses
very very successful you've been working
as an estate agent in london
and you've been helping people thousands
of people buy houses in london
but then you came to the property
investors crash course september 17th
this year so what happened since coming
to the crash course and joining the
academy what's happened since you know
like um i think it's the chain very
changed my life you know even i got
experience before but um i like your
energy
yes
i like the way positive and i think even
academy everyone helping each other to
like to support each other the second
thing is like with the new sauce like
you saucer you know um you saucing right
deal saucing yeah yeah neat saucing like
um
the thingy before i helping people also
get the deal we also get that but now
the more you know a lot of attraction i
got more better deal come you know every
day every way everyone bring the new
came to me and i of course we got the
team we got very good power team you
know some house normally the house will
complete in six months right my power
team will finish in two weeks right yeah
recently last two weeks few hours done
and we got like very efficient one it's
all either way so i i think like it's a
strategy different strategy not focused
on one before i do but not focus on the
formula and everyone but now it's of
course i know exactly what it got what
is that shattering how it has the
formula is that what is the correct
formula so more clear for my investor
and they love it
so you paid eleven nine nine five
twelve thousand pounds to join the
property investors academy which is the
full mentorship and we have you know
obviously parties we were at the party
last night
um mastermind um networking
just a few months ago a couple months
ago first question is have you made your
money back yet yes
on the i think first your week in the
first two weeks yes so how did you
actually do that you know like um with i
think actually i sell one deal i got the
money back already
yes wow like um the way i like got um
yeah the new new salsa yeah of course
with the news yeah
yeah so you you found a property and
then you sold it to an investor and you
how much money did that make uh they
make all i make
fifteen thousand fifteen i think first
um
i think as a member okay first deal
uh after two days i sell this module two
thousand right children flat flat
and after that is a big deal it actually
is a true property selling 15 000 as
instantly like i think eleven
sigma
is the twelve thousand five hundred and
you know like
do you allow the attraction people love
it when they sell even one one customer
i saw them fire house
and they said okay i won't buy a force
you know and i said are you is it yeah
and is it they love it of course you
know
they know they already got experience
they know like the boxes they got is it
good or not yeah i know i always tell
them yeah calculate it do the new reason
yeah even i'm not trying to sell to
anyone i said okay go to go to view know
the new reason
for taco and formula never about
fuelling never about fueling because
because you guys invest not live there
so not about feeling and yeah because
the way with me i'm always clear and
transparent with them so like with me do
the good deal with the deal i would buy
it
and yeah not about like i want to just
i try to sell my investor and i don't
want to to sell it yeah and you've also
bought a property or you're going
through the sales progression on a
property yourself in london yes so how
much are you buying that one for oh not
london brighton oh brighton sorry
brighton the um the buyton one will be
the brighton one yeah actually another
one in london the brighton one how much
forgot already 790. 790. and what is
that are you gonna do that as a buy
refurbished refinance or is it one could
be
i think b-r-r-s-a
right so you're gonna buy it for 7.95
how much money are you going to have to
spend doing it up i think around
seven thousand not much
quite nice already
what so what are you gonna have to do to
the property how are you gonna add value
right now they got seven room yeah i
will can make another they got plan
permission already i can make another
two room
so we'll be
yeah so we'll be night room after that
yeah with um zyphon best and i will do
essay because i got another essay there
well brighton is very good for usa and
in camp town central it do you know i
got 95 percent of occupying last year
yeah for you know actually right after
lockdown is this going to be one that
you can put refinance and pull your
money out of i think what do you think
the end value would be
uh i do with surveyor everything i think
trial 950 950
incredible so that's over that's like
140
000 pounds yes profit on that one deal
yeah you're a real big thinker and
another one in london i discussed with
tony the other day it will be around
i think final one will be around 5.8
million 5.8 million but the thing is
you know in central of london so i have
to make another
another level one make another level one
so yeah add another story to it yeah
around 1.4 million yeah i've seen that
one so how much profit would that make
that one i think we make around 1.4
million so around 700 because i will
partner they view with someone else so
how about that joint venture yeah but um
yeah one is still going on yeah yeah
yeah it takes time yeah everything it
takes time with the property yeah well i
think as well something really important
that you've heard me teach a lot is
about um quick pound quick money and
then your passive slower money slow
burning stuff and you've been making
very quick money from deal selling
wait how much money have you made in
total since joining the academy in deal
selling let me calculate
okay fifteen
uh top with i
okay so around i think let's like around
thirty thirty thousand around thirty to
forty thousand 30 to 40 000 which is
incredible in just two months
but then at the same time you've got
this quick 30 40 000 pounds of money
coming in but then you've also got the
slow stuff which is the brr the service
accommodation which you're buying how
much how much money do you think the
service accommodation property in
brighton how much profit are you
expecting to make on that once you've
bought it um
you mean this other in profit in
brighton yeah i mean the i mean after
the zdv or you yeah once you refinance
it yeah and then you're renting it out a
service accommodation how much money we
expect to make a month
right now with my current one yeah we've
got 70 or 25 000 a month
and you've currently got that set up
yeah no actually i you know i got the
previous one i got one already yes yes
so the second one so my favorite one i
make around 25 so this one i think i i'm
estimate around 28. so you make 25 000
pounds per month ze i think revenue so
actually that all the costs yes so 25
000 is your
your gross turnover and then what about
the profit
i think let's say about 8 000. about 8
000. that's incredible though
on one house and now you've just got
another one you've got your property in
london going through you are building an
empire in i tried either when we go to
academy so the way i do it like with all
the property normally yeah i haven't
take um i got more get but i try to pay
all the mortgage yeah so i would always
remove it out and invest in something
else right refinance it
right exactly yeah because um with the
combo so on i forgot on kamuso in london
the building so i separate the title i
would buy the whole building and they
got full title i separate the title one
and i get remo get it what does your
husband think about what you're doing um
actually um i'm not lucky like
either i can remember my husband didn't
like me
lose the business
it doesn't like you doing the business
yeah in total not property he wanted to
be her wife stay at home
um yeah stay at home take care of my son
and yeah because you are a ridiculously
successful powerful business woman
definitely not designed to be a
housewife only yeah and he he he want me
i'll be home wise and take care yes but
uh with me uh two big work i'm worked
very hard to be honest like
yeah
two three four in the am if i still got
the job to do answer the customer and
with me i with all the business i do i
really want to know from start to the
end what is happening with my customer
and everything i want one way one the
the way i promise or will have to be
complete yeah so with me with my my
client you know with my my client from
vietnam or a different country they came
to uk i helping them to get the business
buy the house and everything settle in
the uk from start to the end not about
only like only came to uk you study only
so like um i feel like uh when there's
always the like life long you know i
follow from start to the end everything
you do
you're a huge massive asset to the
academy and it's i'm so glad that you're
part of the academy thank you so much
what what's the experience been like
with the training and the mentoring over
the last of the last few months i feel
like
i hope like i i hope like i can meet you
earlier than that you know
i think like yeah but um yeah i think it
right home you may be the right time
right person to meet up yet and um yeah
my
in 2020 i looking forward to work with
everyone and with you in academy to
build up my portfolio in property and i
willing to
um go like with all the new and
everything
like especially with development yes
it's so exciting and what would you say
you know you're a very big thinker and
when you do deals you make a lot of
money on the deals
i mean even deal sourcing like we teach
deal sourcing and i'll say right here's
how you make three thousand pounds by
selling a deal you go and sell sell a
deal within two days of the training
bang and then you go and sell a deal the
week after for fifteen thousand like
like you're such a big thinker where
does that come from were you born with
that were you taught that were you
raised that way
do you know like i start my business
when i'm eight years old
yeah my parents visited many women and
they got like the business in in my
country so like when even like
so i started visiting it quite quite
quite young and um even like when i
started in singapore my bachelor degree
in singapore so i also own money to
learn and i didn't get money from my
parents i do even i do rental rent in
singapore you know i got 30 rental rent
in singapore to earn that so i think
everything is accent
like with my
experience have to act
instead of thing you have to do it
yeah think and do it and when you do it
and focus and
deeply inside go to the end not about in
the middle we got a lot even with all
the sector i do i saw a lot of people
start with the same time with me and go
to the middle and they stop and they go
move to different direction and of
course it will be not chill the way not
like that yeah so i think you definitely
go inside and of course you go i think
and the law of attraction
the people you meet you know meet the
more positive people successful people
and like when you meet that
everything will come
and like always transparent clear and
sometimes people don't like direct but
direct always the best you know yeah
sometimes i said that i i some people
said no no it's the thing but when i
drive like people slowly they will love
me more yeah and try to say no way well
you know so i'm not i'm not i always
qualify my customer not all the people i
serve yeah
because my i don't have time for
everything
yes so i think the either the way
practice the more is that the more
confident you got when you got more
confident yeah so you know when i
started i always worry about my innings
that i'm foreigner
igniting my not my third language so
sometimes it's difficult to understand
me but slowly with my busy private
partner and everyone i think is not the
thing
foreigner is not the thing and not like
we have to be
like um morning born in uk and
everything you can be property investor
right you can be everywhere and the
chance is to everyone and even i'm here
i'm not work only in uk i still got you
in dubai vietnam
u.s australia i work with everyone and
you know the good news last two days i
got one new york investor in uh he
visited for me one customer
and
they want to buy the penthouse they move
from new york to london
50 million house
through invest through the furrow so
with me referral is very very important
because the way a lot of my customers
they know me 10 years and they buy the
new for me yeah they not know me one or
two months they know the way i work like
the way they saw it they check it you
know so like they sometimes not come so
quick you know they observe you and they
they check everything so like this
differ so i think my customer 95 is
referral
yeah then we love you they just defer to
you and
when they refer the people don't care
people will trust you yes and we'll
maintain it
how do you manage the time to i mean you
just slip out casually and i've got 30
rent to rent in singapore
that's huge do you know that time i'm
quite young you know like 18 years old
just want to earn money and you know own
your money cover my rent my student
student fee but of course now
i'm not doing rent to rent because i
don't have time for that yeah you know
like i should focus on my business and
everything do you still have those rent
events in singapore no oh so that was
what you did to get started when i
started so do you know like like the way
your way coaster or we have to sometimes
you started it yeah yeah but um yeah so
like to get cash flow yeah so i don't
have um
i don't have to support from start so i
have to start i said like i start with
zero yeah so of course when i start with
zero everyone can start with zero not
about with property not about you have
to get money to start with but work hard
and everything you can get it so you
used rent to get into property you used
rent to rent you did it in singapore you
got 30 rent to rent which made you
financially free and i do i i i when i
go to singapore uk yeah i give all to my
partner and my friend i got zero and
then you came to uk but you have that
experience i got experience i do two
rent to rent one to first when i start
my uni had to get some money to start it
but later on i also stopped because i
want to fork up my study yes because
that time i want to be first in my
master
and um yes so i got it
and i just want to focus on study and my
husband said okay study study focus on
one thing so finite my master and i
thought now is the time to start yeah so
i i start with other business to earn
money after i got money i put in
property what did you study in in
university msc and entrepreneurship like
business
yeah
quite a new cost you know yeah only
eight people in my class interesting and
how was that it got yeah all my lecturer
like from experience uh like not like
the teaching in theory and everything
and where the practice and they're
testing me
yeah so so you so you get a master's in
studying entrepreneurship at university
you then build and a
large companies all these companies
across the world
and then you join my academy you know i
saw the franchise my friend trying now
in india in philippine
thailand vietnam vietnam they got 50 i
think 52 province i already sell 10
province
so my target will send spec vietnam with
my franchise
012 global
well i don't know how you have the time
it's it's it's marvelous just hearing
what was it that made you enroll into
the academy why did you do that
when i first when i go to crash course i
know
the way i know that
i know it's a way um i know is it for me
yes and do it with me i i think it's
like i have to get it on
you know so i told the story when you
start to upset like go to new salsa i
said i want to buy the whole one i want
to buy the complete one i didn't know
the name academy is it tom yes yeah but
um that i i yeah so i said i want to get
in yes because i like um
because i think the catheter we got the
same a bit same character the one that
dominant we want to act on it do it so i
think it's a way it will go we can go
together and yeah what's the training
been like and the mentoring what's it
been like yeah i think i got the support
direct from su from tony and like with
ua world so i think it's quite easy
instead of some time i need the you know
like i'm the
i'm a woman sometimes i
i got some curate something i'm not so
sure
so i think it's a place i need the
advice and everyone is always there with
me yeah and um academy we are together
all the friends yeah i make a lot of
friends and support together not think
about
investor normal but i think the event
you know long-term friend and family as
we can say all the difficult things yeah
didn't lie i think up and down not only
go up right but i think it's a play we
can say i can trust each other do when i
do the business i always ask are you in
academy
so i think easier
to do the business with yeah but because
i think the same mindset the vision we
own the same thing inside if you work in
the same community would be easier than
someone we didn't know because at least
we know got you there yeah and yeah so
people will follow the way even with new
saucer
not everyone understands about how to do
buy the view like we always think you
have to sell my health food you suffer
before i pay you money but the way new
social is different if they are in
academy or they can study through you
and they know how is the process to look
like you know with me selling also the
channel the chaining i have to teach my
customer how to buy the deal because
they always said okay tell me the house
i like it i buy and i pay but listen
you give me the demand what you want
yeah how much of it you want why the
location you want how much money you've
got i find a new for them but is it the
money they have to pay for after that
they pay and of course one hundred
percent my team will work for them and
find the back they'll find the deal
until they're happy with that yeah yeah
but before not not the not to turn
around not the estate is in way of
course i got asked that as a network the
with the portfolio as well but i can
sell them around it's a different way
yeah yesterday when i talked with one in
our academy in cambridge i thought like
when we talked with the my i think like
one you won the vendor give you the how
to rent your rent never think about the
vendor give you the chance we give the
vendor the chance even now you rather
invite you the vendor i said something
i
take the house i guarantee you the rent
you don't need to worry whatever the
brand you want i give you yeah you don't
have the void period i take care of it i
give a professional come there
the how i will be called nicely whenever
you come to you want to come you can
come you can check you got money i got
my business of course i'm not living
there because i got a lot of house i'm
not relieved to take how i'm not live
there and all of all the customer
all my vendors they're happy to give it
and after that i do the delusion i said
it was it or not had to be fair yeah
everyone worked for free and my vendor
said okay i'm upset to offer
little key and i start to helping them
so i think this is the way i'm helping
the vendor not about the vendors helping
us both side win win so i think like
even the vendor said oh thank you
because you know otherwise they give to
how even for some student or someone
else i don't know next month they got
money to pay or not even you know they
check with all the residents even i'm
asian i check with all the ref and
everything but even next month they they
got the salary there but not guaranteed
they can pay the rent next month even
they keep the house nicely or not but
we're there to manage and everything
yeah so do you do
rent to rent in london
um i'm not i think i tried
actually like i already did two when in
2011 i came to uk
after that i'm not do it because my
visit is quite busy so recently when i
saw the course um
like i think recently we ran to rent
recently in
november is it december right in
december but i try myself i want to
challenge myself but i want to challenge
i want to apply whatever you teach me
the third one the customer say no
you know the whole day i try it's hard
people say no second day i chain a bit
and i know who the person said yes i
came to meet them and you know i got one
yes from one
vendor after that second third all of
them happy with me
but i'm not doing any of them i saw it
okay so you secure them but then you
sell it yeah i'm not i give to my uh
some of my friends and i thought the way
to do it because um i don't have time
because yeah so i think but i i'm happy
i'm feel i
i feel like i complete the challenge i
completed it so you did it just for the
learning experience yeah i want to learn
but i know it's hot on the first you
know on the first day even i call tony i
said tony i'm so upset
everyone say no to me
and you know like even i said like i
messaged them it's a company no is it
the corporate net no um is it um uh is
it my phone my staff there no
okay so i have to be live there another
day i train a bit technique i talk to
them but i think like japan
always come to talk to them i think your
confidence though helps the fact that
you go in with business acumen a couple
of questions for you then so quick
question quick answer number one best
country in the world to invest what do
you think okay do you reckon all right
next question best city to invest in the
uk go
london oh
london interesting okay is the market in
london do you think over the next five
years gonna boom or gonna crash in
london
um
actually like with me my experience is
the best but depends on the deceleration
because now i try to do something
outside london because with earth
support like the formula always follow
the london yeah because sometimes follow
the formula by
by by no fan height yeah i will so i
discovered some place to to put my uh
portfolio in so actually
i start london because
more of my property in london so is
london going to go up or is it going to
go down
what do you think
i think we go up but not much okay but
the good thing about what you're doing
is you're buying in london but you're
pushing the value up you're forcing the
value up so even if it doesn't boom
you're gonna make it boom because you
create your own economy so and what
you've done all through you know the
pandemic and lockdowns you've been
building and you've been growing is
ridiculously impressive what would be
your advice to somebody
thinking about coming to a property
investors crash course what would you
say i think go for it i would i tell my
friend and my my partner go for it when
you go in the different you know the
chance is really different and when you
go through it act on it do it instead of
think no thing no time for think and of
course with one power in crosstalk why
not it not cost you anything yeah and
the academy obviously is a big
investment so the academy you know we we
interview people and we have a we have a
shortlist process um what would you say
to somebody that was maybe thinking
about going to the academy that had the
money that had the the capacity to do it
that really wanted to go and pursue
property what would you say to somebody
wanting to do the academy i think with
ten thousand like two thousand
you can
you know you can in you difficult to i
think can you feel rendering or buy some
sauce but long list your own way the
first always got the question is the
first the best investor you invent for
yourself right so not the second one is
the property yes so i think
if they got it go for it because when
you go it not about the training not
about the course of course you are
brilliant already but seconding a
community together and we we got we we
trust the person in there and we can go
for it yeah and i think like instead of
pay even me
i buy few more deals or something before
i have to learn you know i have people
buy one thousand house i got a lot of
mistake in their wealth you know even
more myself but i think when you pay
when you learn you don't make the
mistake even like you know i tell all my
my investor what my mistake is that and
of course never never like never go for
the mistake again so i think when they
go with academy everyone says story
experience i don't know let me maybe
never make a mistake before i met
you know yeah so i think it's um go for
it amazing and final question what is
your plan in england through property
over the next two years what are you
hoping to achieve over the next two
years i think um i will focus for a few
vr
second thing in development yes yeah
this is the one i focus on really
excited i don't want to say
congratulations on your success thank
you for being part of the academy thank
you for being a friend and a student of
mine but also a friend and i'm really
excited about helping you go to a whole
new level and thanks for sharing your
story thank you so much for today thank
you very much so i hope you enjoyed that
guys i hope you're inspired if you are
why don't you go ahead and hit the like
button subscribe drop a comment and if
you want to come to the property
investors crash course or do further
training i will leave a link in the
description with free tickets limited
spaces so get booked on right now and
i'll see you guys next time god bless